умовах інформатизації істоти
поступово може this bitch увійти
навантаження центральні nervous system
the organizers to визріти цієї
дошкільного віку і відносять ширше нам
таких порушення зору як амбліопія
коротко зорі сталь на заздрість до свого
кисть астигматизм.
порушення бінокулярного то лад
ступичного за раз завдають вигляду цього
неврози кузови хочу тиф і верстата вас
розуміння на поличці ви самі та ще
coloros прайма нерозрізна тяги з
підстригайте синдром зниження зарублю в
є в турині with you in і потім до
психічного розвитку треба хіба цей
процесі визнаючи діяльність фея
спадщиною по три монети підлогу.
для точної ігрової інформації церкви
війна за свою нього три моні інформації
розвинена процесі забувайте аудіо
загиблі прогнози на подалі нальчани
школі всі роки не в мою організацію
корекції на під одиничного процесу
нових спеціальних установок любить і з
води ми сварю
допомагаєте стиснути нові технології
з'їдаючи спи знайку створі не комфорті у
нової спеціальної кабінету та
то плита засовуєте комп'ютер не
програма який є елементом
здоров'язберігаючих технологій та дітей
дошкільного віку з водами зуби
на етапах заслуховування комп'ютерні
технології в куркою на під та логічному
процесі вирішує власного
завдання
пропедевтики здорових чи психомоторних
порушень розвиток вибуху вас прямо не в
пункті
стабілізація хіба над їхніми функціями
комплекс на реабілітацію дні є
дільничних програм є
комп'ютерна програма до та цілому часточки
Чи ти на гру реформі призових зубці
через думав про нього статеві кулер
а храм чудовий варіант гри з монітором
проси вчися клавіатури малюків та визнання
показуємо називаючи і адже двоє на плівці
положення киньте
вчитель-дефектолог герою процесом
вибухнула прямо не ілюстративний
матеріал з меншим розміром кольор
контрастність та насиченість на площі
кенієць вздовж
кільки спам та лота результативність
роботи фіксується комп'ютером тебе
програма спрею розшук близько 1 розуміння
здорово моторної координації
по 2 орієнтування з поточного разу
справі концентрації переключи на інший
рівень
чіпаю перевірити цією програмою в дужки
нам побачити її калейдоскоп вся програма
до чи допомагає ти небес кличе shoes in
тут немає і корекцію це відро
хворих то психофізичних функцій
пизда не пас велася пряма через на
кулер та зображенні вигляди калейдоскоп
біля річки майже на зраді резину по
дальності
ось різниця гангліозних ти не сітки
психолога, до чого й досягається
значний вид dowley війни та фред
інших функцій доступним крихтам дані
цієї патології є ви щурів-то не
комп'ютерних програм христа кита павучок
деякі при значенні для бачив і
нездорових функцій зірки дружини та
контрасту вчить вивести - прийняти розвідку
навколишніх функцій від нав'язати vizio
моторної діяльності
так програмах якраз і ігровим
патерн симуляторів я кому ви коростово
і c inverto чия шахова підлога і пити годину
ігри clit and подрібнюють цю величину
право разу видання код разу проживання
варіюється в широких лижах
али біля roxio зайняті по щоках
Якщо здійсняться різанини на і в тому
числі детектори контрасту руху
орієнтації авторизується процесі носить
kitty
програмі павучок стимуляція тут насті
складним динамічним за проживання та рій
завдання спав до цієї 303 мелений
paulig у центрі лаючих радіальних та
спіральних спливти і не дай не програм
із розвитку бінокулярного зору
он і може пута ви просто не сама стіна
обидві жінки у правому та для бачила
немічні radan вапна
і від скрині віднесе кирки так і в
центральних with key lock здорового
аналізатора
тренінгом обливати і це розвитку
знатністю дозорова пор штуку і
локалізації силуетне зображення
комп'ютерна програма квітка при лагами
c та програми можна поважати із землею
чикурова рішення хренового приклад
звуку здорові уваги
внески суворих образі 2 моторної
координації а ви karust вони окулювати
за бражник змініть у наказують троянди ту
вибухи в тому ці піни
комп'ютерна програма контуру просто
тазах про ключ гра для малютки
дитину ви хрестову частину петрушки diy
рука біля обидва лівий контур зображення
у мій це розвивай бінокулярні зерги
широкого хрестового цирку рік тину
патологічні роботі тут мій
комп'ютер на програма релакс для
занять азарової в тому це розслаблення
очних міозин тебе програмою та
мультифункціональний таємницею пити по
ширину і ми можемо хрестового тосіо
накидки спеціальних а і в завального
кольорових закладок мультимедійні версії
здоров'ям нас таксі більше затікав лід
китай і своє черви є
профілактикою здорових порушено збити на
її оточуючих до Азії
куріть розумом успішно займається dos
шинки логопед я як провід же влада
не оригінальні прийоми та методики за
рукава не їм здорові діагнозі у дітей
індивідуально варіаторі не спить час
маузер сприймаючи програм гуляй одопту
вати матеріал то суворих пазли з тієї
шкірної дотени вчитель-дефектолог
ос зазвичай вибираю модифікації зображено
контрастність я приховую
товщину контуру ви permalink а доступним
склад настей розмір тай інь чи параметр
така система ви хреста не дані
технології даємо вузли весь у повному up
these price 3 реабілітації не заходи в
колекції на патологічному процесі
важливу психологічно мото соціальному
плані
ієни обхідну у мовою для подалі
мовчання у школі
а